[Music]
Christian
St
[Music]
good even
evening hi everybody it's good to see
your faces welcome my name is Karen
Miner my pronouns are she her and I'm so
glad you're here welcome to July at the
table uh this is the first Sunday of
July uh and so we're doing our first
Sunday meal immediately after the
service uh we'll head over to hat Creek
Burger Company it is right off of 78 and
would bridge in
saxi and uh this is just something we do
the first Sunday of every month to help
connect people here at the table uh we
all need to eat and uh it's a great
place to to do that so we'll be heading
over to hat Creek after the service
tonight each and every one of you are
welcome to join us there and I also want
to say uh a special hello to those who
are visiting for the first time tonight
and those who are joining us online so
glad that you're here um other than hat
Creek uh the other announcement I have
is that July at the table is a time
where we lean into more rest than usual
and so our pastor Brett his wife Maggie
our worship leader Mindy they take the
month of July off to rest to
recoup to remember that God is God and
they are not and the church still goes
on and on and so uh the really cool
thing about that although we miss Brett
and Maggie and Mindy a lot while they're
gone we get the opportunity to hear from
amazing guest speakers and guest worship
leaders and uh so I'm thrilled tonight
that we have Dr Aaron brownbrook as our
guest speaker who also multi-talented as
he is is also singing tonight and then
our worship leader is none other than
the amazing Jesse
Watts yeah
Dad number one fan over there um so I
hope all of you will also Embrace a
posture of rest this month and just find
those moments in your day or your week
where you can maybe not try so hard
maybe not strive as much maybe not let
work take control as much and just allow
yourself to
breathe and to
be and to
rest so let's take that posture as we
enter into
worship close your eyes if you're
comfortable doing so take a deep breath
in let it
out one more time in
and
out let's be here now set aside the day
and the week
ahead be
present this time as a
gift pray with me God thank you for
tonight thank you for this
community thank you for every person
here and those watching on online I pray
your blessings over
them and I pray God that we would
connect with you
tonight that we would feel peace in our
hearts much needed rest in our
bodies and
hope for our days in Jesus name
amen why don't you go ahead and stand
with us
[Music]
sometimes on this joury get lost my
mistakes looks to me like
weaknesses can strength
my story isn't over my story's just
begun fa you won't me that's what father
does you w me that's what my father
does lay your burdens
[Music]
down here in the father's house check
game at the door it ain't welcome
anymore
o you're in the father's
[Music]
House's not the end game the Journey's
where you are you never want to perfect
you just want in my
heart and the story isn't over if the
story isn't good enough failures never
final when the father's in the room I
said failures never find when the
father's in the room wo
wo lay your burdens down wo wo
here in the father's house check his
shame at the door it ain't welcome
anymore wo
wo you're in the father's
[Music]
house girls come home
hope is fine
hope love is on the moon when the
father's in the
room prison do swing
wide dead come to
life love is on the moon when the
father's in the
room Miracles take
place
cical love is breaking through when the
father's in the room
Jericho's walls quaking strongholds now
shaking love break it through when the
father is in the
room break through when the father's in
the
room lay your burdens down wo
wo here in the father's house check your
shame at the door say welcome
anymore w
w you're in the father's
[Music]
house no shame here no fear
all right kiddos you can go ahead and
head to your classrooms with your
teachers with your teachers
[Music]
please and so at this time we do
something called uh prayers of the
people and this is something that the
church has done throughout history for a
long time and what we do we're going to
read uh read a prayer together and then
there'll be some space for you to either
say a name of someone that you want our
community uh to be praying for it's
basically like adding to a pool of
prayer like we throw a name in we throw
a situation in like maybe it's finances
maybe it's you know someone specifically
you know who's struggling or maybe it's
something for yourself you can even say
your own name here um but this is this
is a really beautiful time for us to uh
pray together in this way so Gary's
going to lead us through
for the city of saxi Texas and for every
city and community and all who live in
them we pray to you for the Good Earth
you have given us and the wisdom and the
will to conserve it we pray to you for
the old and the sick for the Widow and
orphan for the injured and suffering we
pray to you for the poor and the
oppressed the unemployed and destitute
for prisoners and captives and all who
remember and care for them we pray to
you for the vulnerable the marginalizes
and those unjustly targeted for their
gender sexuality race or other preceived
difference we pray to you and for those
experiencing loss loneliness and
disconnection and for those struggling
with mental and emotional health pray
pray to you Lord we know that you love
us that you hear us so we lift these
names and situations up to you
[Music]
for the names and the moments we have
spoken aloud and for those we've kept in
our hearts we pray to you that they may
have life and light healing and hope
peace and a deep sense of your presence
amen
[Music]
let the king of my heart be the mountain
where I run the fountain I drink from oh
he is my
song Let the king of my heart be the
shadow where I hide the ransom for my
life oh he is my song cuz you are
good
oh you are
oh you are good you're
good
oh you are
good oh
oh let the king of my heart be the wind
inside
mys the anchor in the waves oh is my
S let the king of my heart be the fire
inside my veins the echo of my days oh
he is my
song with the King
of my heart be the fire inside my veins
the echo of my days oh he is my song you
are
good
oh you are
good good
good
oh you're never going to let never going
to let me
down you're never going to let never
going to let me
going to let me die
you're never going
to let never
know you're never going to let never
going to let me
down you're never going to let never
going to let me down
never going to let never going to let me
down you are
good
oh you are
good wo
oh never going to let never going to let
me
down never going to let never going to
let me
down you're never going to let never
going to let me you you are
good
oh you are
good oh sing that out you are good you
are
[Music]
good you are
and
I
[Music]
you want to be
with you are
and I
call
[Music]
you and you came to my resue
and want to be
where you are
[Music]
falling on my knees in
worship giving all I am to seek your all
face Lord all I am is
[Music]
yours I place in your hands God of
Mercy
humbl I bow
down in your pra
your
throne
in
you and you came to my rescue and
die what to be
where you are
[Music]
I
you then you came to my resue and
I want to be with you
in my
life be lifted high in our
world be lifted high in our
love be lifted
High sing that in my
life in my life
be lifted high in our
world be lifted high in
all be
[Music]
lifted
[Applause]
my be lifted
in
World be
lift
[Applause]
in be lifted
high in
[Applause]
my be lifted high in my world
be lifted high
[Music]
and be
lifted I
call you
[Music]
answer and you came to my resue
I want to be
with
you
[Music]
are I
call you
answer and you came to my resue and
[Music]
be
with
you
are oh mysterious Christ we are
grateful Lord we may not even truly
understand what that rescue means that
we are
grateful for all the ways you rescue Us
big and small seen and
[Music]
unseen Lord I ask that every heart in
this room would be tilled like good soil
ready to hear
from we ask this in your name
[Music]
amen if you would turn to your neighbors
say hello smile do something awkward
anything to just make someone feel
welcome thank you thank you worship team
that was great you know they only
rehearsed one time and that happened at
2 p.m today like that's incredible that
just blows my mind I wish I could do
that yeah
so I have the pleasure and honor of
introducing our guest speaker come on
down this is my friend Dr Aaron Brown
Brook yes so Aaron and his husband Lance
uh and their kiddos have been longtime
friends of the table uh in fact I
remember having many conversations
before we started the table about the
what about what the table was going to
be and so they are they have been there
from the beginning with us in Spirit uh
and actually uh Aaron was the pastor of
an open and affirming church called
church at teoma up in Sherman and how
long was that church around I know it
was through covid which counts for like
10 extra years yeah 2018 to like 2022
yeah yeah so the multi-talented Aaron
obviously musician singer
speaker what are you Pro now as a tennis
player um world
traveler Aaron just has this zest for
life that is amazing uh and uh he's a
theologian knows his Bible um like I
could go on and on but I won't because
we want to hear from you and not me so
I'm so glad you're here thank you for
saying yes and uh just help me in
welcoming Aaron
[Applause]
okay I'm staying down here thank you
everybody um like Karen said this always
feels like home um we were a part of
getting things started we love that like
it's just been a group of people that
Lance has known and love for a long time
who I feel like very warmly adopted me
when we were getting married so that's
always wonderful um I love absolutely
love what you do here and thank thank
you for letting me sing I always
appreciate that thank you so much um
like Karen said I am an amateur
Theologian Seminary
dropouts um but I am a very real
psychiatrist and that will show as we go
through this sermon um so I really lean
on a lot of let's look at scripture
let's see what it was trying to tell us
we do know the scripture was written at
a particular time to a particular people
with a particular ular message and so
the lessons don't always directly apply
so I do try to take those apply them to
where we are now and then try to give us
some real practical skills to just make
our life better that's my jam um but
let's start off with
prayer so oh great love thank you for
living and loving in us and through us
may all that we do flow from our deep
connection with you and all beings help
us become a community that vulnerably
shares each other's burdens in the
weight of Glory listen to our heart's
longings for the healing of our world
knowing you are hearing us better than
we are speaking we offer these prayers
in all the holy names of God
Amen okay so today we're going to be
taking a look at the sign of
Jonah um a hysterical look in the mirror
and so we're going to be starting with
uh Matthew 12 this is verses 38 through
42 I'll go ahead and read them for us
then some of the scribes and Pharisees
said to him teacher we want to see a
sign from you but he answered and said
to them an evil and adulterous
generation craves for a sign and yet no
sign will be given to it but the sign of
Jonah the prophet for just as Jonah was
three days and three nights in the belly
of the sea monster so will the son of
man be three days and three nights in
the heart of the Earth
the men of neveh will stand up with this
generation at the judgment and will
condemn it because they repented at the
preaching of Jonah and behold something
greater than Jonah is here the queen of
the South will rise up with this
generation at the judgment and will
condemn it because she came from the
ends of the Earth to hear the wisdom of
Solomon and behold something greater
than Solomon is
here uh so a little bit of background to
this
I think one thing that gets lost for us
now is that the Bible's all broken up
into chapters and verses and so we tend
to look at it as chapters and verses and
forget that it was not written that way
um so if I write you an entire letter
and you send me like this one excert and
you're like I analyze this and this is
what I think you mean and it's like you
probably could have just looked at the
whole letter and found out what I meant
would have been obvious um so we're not
going to forget to do that so if we look
at this book as a whole part of what
Matthew is doing is he's using the
Pharisees he's using the scribes really
as a literary device I doubt the
Pharisees were this one-dimensional
where they were really like these little
villains who just popped up wherever
Jesus went to be like oh look here this
is wrong that is wrong like they
probably still had somewhat of a life um
but Matthew uses him as this really cool
literary device to really pound on
hypocrisy and there are two things that
show up in Matthew quite a bit actually
Matthew uses the word hail more than any
other book of the Bible in large part
Matthew is talking about gehenna this
place where things were thrown into the
fire and what Matthew is always getting
at is all things that are fake are going
to be burned up and Chown for what they
are one day so what Matthew is really
pounding on is
hypocrisy Jesus says that all the time
throughout Matthew you Hypocrites you
Hypocrites that's what he keeps saying
to the religious leaders and then he'll
follow up with some parable about
somebody who was burned in the fire high
and some people who are okay it's this
whole idea that your hypocrisy is going
to show itself for what it is so if we
look directly at chapter 12 that's what
happens everywhere that Jesus goes
throughout chapter 12 the Pharisees pop
up to be like haha they ate food on the
Sabbath haha they did this they did that
and so we have this whole chapter of
haha Pharisee things uh followed by
Jesus saying the only sign that you'll
get is the sign of Jonah and now if we
know the story of Jonah then this
becomes a real obvious connection what
Jesus is saying um but for most of us
what happens is we just get caught up on
the
whale Jesus talks about the great fish
and we go the fish three days and Jesus
was buried for three days oh my god um
and the reason that I think we get so
caught up just on that is because we
learn the story of Jonah when it's just
about the whale like we all learned the
story of Jonah in Sunday school when we
were six and the only thing they really
taught us was that there was a great
whale um I Heard a comedian who I think
finally made this clear for me there are
so many things that we tell kids like
these are our Bible stories for kids
that I don't get like let's teach kids
about the flood because there's animals
like let's teach kids about the time
when God decided to wipe out most of the
earth um and the comedian was like she
thinks this is just like basically a
parable for children like hey I'm going
to stick these animals on your wall to
remind you what God did when his
children didn't know
bad remember
that but the real story of Jonah has
like this much to do with the whale
really um and so today I am going to
give you the nerd adult retelling of the
story of
Jonah we're going to get
there there we
go okay so once upon a time there was a
man called Joan a snow um and God went
to Jonah snow and God said I am going to
send you to preach basically to your
worst enemies and I just want you to let
them know that word of their misdeeds
has missed me has come to me and so I
want you to go down and let them know I
know what they've been doing and they
have 40 days to p and Jonah was
basically like nah ain't about that life
my dad went down there to talk to him
once and in episode 8 they cut his head
off um so so I will not be going um
Jonah instead hops on a boat and fleas
down to tarus now this is kind of funny
this shows what kind of book Jonah is
like they're very much using these
literary devices God keeps saying go up
to this place and preach go up to this
place and then every time Jonah disobey
he goes down somewhere else so he hops
on a ship to go down to tarus while he's
on the ship he goes down to the bottom
of the boat and meanwhile this boat has
hit a huge storm everyone on the boat is
just freaking out they're all offering
prayers and sacrifices to their own Gods
none of their prayers are working so
they go down they find Jonah asleep
which is another joke like he's the one
person who's asleep during all of this
Jonas basically f is up he's like yeah
this is my fault kids like I disobeyed
God I'm here God's getting me back so
the only solution is to throw Jonah off
the boat what else can you do um they
throw Jonah off the boat Jonah's like I
regret nothing I did what I had to do
meanwhile everybody else on the boat
repents they all go oh apparently his
God is the right God they repent of
everything they ever could have done
wrong and they go Jonah still upset the
part that we all know at some point
Jonah runs into the great fish which we
call the whale um the part that you
probably didn't read in your Bible is
where Jonah goes hey beasty and they
have a whole fight and he's in there for
three days um after three days Jonah
finally fights his way
out he tells God hey sorry Jonah finally
at least he doesn't fully repent but
he's like I should do what I want to I
should at least do what you told me to
do Jonah goes to Nineveh and preaches
the worst sermon you've ever heard like
I want you to go look this up in the
Book of Jonah it's like one sentence he
just says basically judgment's coming
for you in 40
days that's it like he doesn't say you
should repent he doesn't say judgment's
coming but God's willing to forgive you
if like the sorest sermon you've ever
heard which is basically just judgment's
coming me meanwhile the city of Neva is
like this they're repenting left and
right the Pentecostals are like running
down the
AIS we got Baptist putting on a full
show and then we
have we even the king of Neva
immediately repeats it repats imagine
this like seriously imagine Coming to
America
in 2018 and this happens and even Trump
is like yes I
Repent right and then the funniest thing
ever like he even makes them go do
sacrifice everyone here is going to go
give sacrifices for themselves we're
going to repent he even says do
sacrifices for the animals like the
animals have been somewhat sinning in
all of this like what is happening so
everybody repents and meanwhile Jonah is
like this
oh not like that thank God Jonah was
like that I'm tired of this church so
everyone in this story now has repented
the people on the boat everyone in the
city the leaders of the city the animals
have all repented except for the one who
already thought he had mate Jonah's
supposed to be the hero of the story
Jonah's the only one in the whole story
who does doesn't actually
repent and that's what the story is
really about the religious leaders the
scribes the Pharisees who are the ones
saying we're already in the in group
we're the ones who God already loves we
already have the relationship with God
and they were the ones who would not
repent so let's take a quick look so you
can see
it because it's really exaggerated so
this is the people on the boat so they
picked up Jonah they threw him into the
sea and the Sea stopped his raging then
the men feared the Lord greatly and they
offered a sacrifice to the Lord and made
vows secondly this is at the end then
the people of Nineveh believed in God
and they called a fast and put on
sackcloth from the greatest to the least
of them when the word reached the king
of n OFA he arose from his throne laid
aside his robe from him covered himself
with sackcloth and set on the ashes both
man and Beast must be covered in
sackcloth and let men call on God
earnestly that they may turn from his
Wicked way and from the violence which
is in his hands so here's the real irony
for me about how we've picked up this
story um we have this story of the
Israelites through this book calling
themselves out this is what they were
really doing in Jonah this was a slick
way of sub subversive way of them saying
y'all this is us we keep running around
talking about how we're God's people and
meanwhile everywhere else they're
repenting and doing what God is calling
them to do it's not us and somehow we
have picked up the story from the
Israelites and we have said well
actually that's because the story was
actually about us as
Christians and all those other people
need to start repenting and doing what
we're doing we ironically fell right
back into the same trap and I think
that's because we're really poor at
self-reflection and now the psychiatrist
in me gets really picky about this I
think the reason that we're bad at
self-reflection is because we just don't
really have the tools to do it I don't
get so much into uh our ideals of moral
failings I think that tends to mess us
up I think when people get into the idea
of like I'm a moral failure they just
get anxious and they do worse when you
can say this life is what it is this is
what I've been doing I'm going to learn
new
skills way easier um and so that's what
we're going to really lean on today so
the first skill we're going to talk
about is neutralizing and naming our
emotions so just a quick intro there um
when I talk about neutralizing what I am
basically talking about is removing any
idea of judgment from what you
feel so so a lot of us grew up and this
happens in church this happens at home
it happens everywhere people have ideals
of what they should feel in every
situation um if you're with someone you
love then you're always supposed to feel
butterflies and you're always supposed
to feel in love and so anytime we feel
aggravated frustrated any of those
things we kind of freak out we start
judging I shouldn't feel this way um we
think men are supposed to feel more
aggressive women aren't all these things
we come up with all these ideas of
judgment about how we're supposed to
feel
and as long as we have those judgments
in our head we won't be able to identify
how we're actually
behaving same things the Pharisees would
do they had this idea of how they were
supposed to look as religious leaders
and meanwhile they were totally unaware
of how they were actually behaving and
how people actually felt when they were
around them so we got to neutralize
those ideas and then we got to learn how
to name them so as far as neutralizing
let's take a look this is the first
thing I would tell you to take a look at
that is a DNA strand in the back if
you're trying to make that picture out
um so much of who we are and our
personalities is actually
genetic it's genetic some of it is also
how we're raised that plays its part of
environmental stressors all those things
but so much how we in respond to how
we're
raised has to do with the genetics we
were born with let me show you a little
bit more
so we cut personality types into really
five different types neuroticism
extraversion openness agreeableness and
conscientiousness we can map these to
certain physiology in your brain okay so
when you think about how anxious I get
and think about a Bible verse like do
not be
anxious because that's always calmed
people down don't be anxious um some of
these things you're just born with some
people are born with the brain
physiology that's going to make them
more neurotic some people are going to
be more open um all of these different
things you didn't control that that was
never within your control so why judge
it why waste time on that um I think
about how much of that we sin judging
even other people like this person gets
angry and this person's too passive and
all of those things and so much of that
is just the genes we're born with no
reason to judge so then if that's the
case now oh will you go back now all we
need to do is start working on the
naming part so Karen will you help me
out can we email this out yay um so I
just want you to have this this is a
great technique just to help you name
what you feel because most of us just
weren't given language for it we may
have like two different words for angry
and that makes life difficult um because
sometimes I need you to know that I'm
furious sometimes I need you to know
that I'm just like mildly
agitated I'm a little frustrated all of
those things and that's actually really
helpful for you as well further as we
look at the different colors which kind
of represent different types of emotion
you just have to know that some people
are more prone to certain things some
people are going to get angrier first
some people are more on the joy side of
things some people are more on the love
side of things
things absolute zero judgment but it's
really smart for you to know yourself
because if you know yourself now you can
know how to respond to certain
situations um I do know that there are
certain things that going to make me
just furious and so if I know that ahead
of time I can already choose how I want
to respond like I have chosen that this
is how I want to respond to these
certain situations
um right out of residency I moved to
Sherman that's where the church was um I
grew up in Dallas when when I moved to
Sherman like I experienced racism like I
hadn't before like the idea of
microaggressions but I had to make a
decision like internally I was angry did
I want to be the angry black guy no um
so I made decisions I said okay how I
want to respond is I want to teach
people what they should do hey in this
situation you say this this is why
that's offensive can we do this and say
it turned out it worked great but I had
to know that about myself ahead of time
because when I'm angry my first thought
is not to teach
well maybe it is but it's to teach
something very different
um teach something very different but
since I knew that about myself I could
make different decisions and it's the
same so if we're not aware of what we
feel we just kind of act it out instead
here's another good exercise that I want
you to try at home this one's good at to
look at because it's just a little bit
simpler um this is also helpful just for
you so a good meditative exercise to do
is that you can use these to help
identify what you feel because we all
know and especially I think in
relationships we get triggered in weird
ways like somebody says something and
before we know it like we're either
really angry or we're really sad or we
feel abandoned and we don't know why
that hit some
cord um but now we're trying to deal
with it so this can be good for helping
you just identify what that feeling is
we don't have to analyze it we just
identify what it is and then a part of
the meditation is just imagining the
ocean and that emotions just like the
ocean they come in they go out and you
let the emotions do the same thing so
rather than feel like we have to control
the emotion like we have to try to make
ourselves feel something different we
just let the emotions flow just like the
ocean they flow in they flow out they
come and they go if I give it 5 Seconds
I'll probably feel Joy here in just a
second I don't know so it's just that
meditation of letting those things come
and letting them
go all
right okay so our next thing is
decentering uh decentering is a really
complex idea actually um we have way
oversimplified it so if you hear this
now everybody's like somebody should be
decentered like all the time like Des
Center White straight males Des Center
these people just decentering somebody
to for someone else never works and
that's why we have all this Whiplash
because none of us are really made for
that have you tried that in a
relationship where it was like for the
next three months I'm not going to think
about myself I'm only going to think
about my partner wonderful for the first
two weeks you feel so good about
yourself they feel good and then after
like three months you're like that's
selfish bastard and then it's like all
about you like we're just
not we're not made for this idea of like
I'm just going to put myself to the side
and put these people in front here's the
key though no one really has to be at
the center at all so I'm going to show
you an experiment that happened so if
you are an educator you probably know PJ
he's done a lot of work as far as child
development so he has this thing that
develops between about seven or 12 um
decentering or he called it centration
and so here's what happened before about
7 to 12 kids can't tell you what the
person on the other side of the table
would
see so they have mountains on the table
they could draw a picture of you of what
that whole scene looked like from their
point of you if you ask them then well
can you draw what the other person sees
they just draw the same thing and
psychologically this is the thing that
sticks with us in life we can't draw
what other people would see apart from
how we see
things and so we walk in a room people
are talking they laugh we s where
they're laughing about us why because we
have put ourselves at the center of
everything and that's where being at the
center of everything Cuts both ways it
can feel good to be the center of
attention and it can be really bad to be
the center of attention and I had a
patient of mine who put this the best
way ever he goes I feel like I am
constantly either Kanye or a
mircat
like I have I am full of just unearned
confidence
or I am just so down on myself I can
barely
function and this is what happens when
we Center ourselves too much because now
everything that everyone else does has
to mean something about me and I have to
figure that out now here's where it gets
tricky once again we're not trying to
take myself out of the center so we can
see someone else in there what we're
learning to do is see that picture from
on top
so now I can see how all the pieces move
I don't stop looking at how I feel about
things too so if you take this actually
the smallest number so if you take this
just in terms of a couple you don't take
your own feelings off the table when
this happens I still feel this it
affects me this way I want to do these
things but when my partner experiences
these things I know from what I've
learned about them that this trigger
this experience that they had before
these things are happening in their body
they start to feel these emotions all of
a sudden I can come on top and I can see
why we're
fighting and it has nothing to do with
the fact that they just don't care about
my feelings and it has nothing to do
with the fact that I'm just not good
enough it just happens to be that
there's this weird equation that hits
right here and that's where we throw
down every
time because my old experience is
meeting up with their old experience and
we're throwing down and that's the way
to decenter the whole thing I'm not at
the center they're not at the center the
we're just two people having two
experiences at the same time in the same
place and now a way that you can
practice doing this I think is to take
your own family story like write your
family story from when you were born up
till
now and I want to tell you you start
filling in blanks calling people asking
questions what were you going through at
the time then all of a sudden you not
being at the center starts to feel
really good because one thing that
happens and if you've been to therapy it
can come really easy to go to therapy
and you come out and basically I'm the
hero and everybody else in my story were
either Disney villains or
Sidekicks cuz I'm the center and imagine
what happens when everybody's a villain
or sidekick like I never have a peer I
never have a good idea of life I either
have really negative interactions or I
have really positive interactions
there's no reason no room for the middle
um and so if you go back and you write
these stories you can be really honest
like I was this age I needed a place to
feel
safe um I needed people in my life who
could protect me I needed parents who
could understand me and help me
understand things about myself I didn't
even get that's very real you never take
yourself out of the story but then there
may be things like but then at the same
time I had a father who was dealing with
these things this is how he grew up my
mom was dealing with that and so it just
becomes a big
neutral at the end of the day everybody
had
experiences um and we don't have to put
anyone at the center of that we just
start to recognize where it is and that
gives us a chance to look at ourselves
honestly otherwise what we see in the
mirror is always going to be in this
convex kind of messed up mirror but if
we're really going to see ourselves
honestly for who we are we got to
decenter all right last
thing is
humor so if you go to the next
one so here's what I this is a very
messy slide um please don't try to read
it
but the only thing I really wanted you
to see is that there's our list of
defense mechanisms a lot of these you
know like denial
projection um reaction formation you
probably don't know unless you went to
school but most of those things you've
heard of right and so humor is the
second most mature defense mechanism we
have that's what I want you to
recognize humor's
wonderful and that's actually the reason
that Jonah was written the way it was to
the people at the time Jonah would have
been an SNL
skit like the people like the boat talks
the boat thinks about whether or not is
going to tear apart like it's a big SNL
skit and they would have picked that up
we didn't because it wasn't written
directly to us but it was a big SNL skit
because one of the best ways to see
yourself well is to inject humor and why
because sometimes seeing yourself well
hurts we have to see some parts of
ourselves that are hard to deal with we
see parts of ourselves that other people
told us weren't acceptable all of these
things and that can bring up a lot of
negative emotion and one easy way to
counter that is with humor now here's
the thing that I really want to point
out about humor there is a difference
between like this just
self-deprecating I use humor basically
as a way of just deflecting attention
and getting away from this and then
there is the humor that comes from I've
neutralized a situation uh Lance and I
have a blast like sometimes we'll go
back and we'll be like how did we get
here like we're in the middle of ready
like gearing up and we're like how did
we get here and we go back and we kind
of look at it well this thing happened
you said this and then we just kind of
laugh we're like humans are
funny like in real life there was act no
actual real threat to either one of
us like we're two adult men with good
jobs and cars and money and a house like
there was zero actual threat in the
situation but we felt
it oh we felt it um and just that
ability to kind of go back and laugh at
ourselves elves and how we got here is a
huge part of the whole thing um so
putting this
together um what we're really looking at
is when we look at the sign of Jonah
what Jesus was always pointing at to the
Pharisees was just this idea of you keep
asking for more you keep trying to point
out everybody else's hypocrisy and at
the end of the day it's not about what's
going to come and that's kind of where
we take it and this is actually one way
I think we escape ourselves we just gow
we look at Jesus I know I do all these
things but then I look to Jesus and it's
all forgiven there's work for you to
do there is work for you to do even
after you're forgiven the work of
reconciliation is very real and that's
what Jesus is pointing them to you're
looking for a sign you're looking to the
miraculous and I'm pointing you back to
the
mundane you sitting and taking a look
with
yourself doing it in all these nice
functional ways and watch how that will
improve the way you interact with other
people and the way you feel about
yourself um so with that being said I
would love for us to read our prayer of
confession
together I tried really hard to just
make this funny but I'm not that funny
so I couldn't do it um so we're just
going to read it straight up okay God of
compassion and mercy you sent us your
son as the savior of the world and told
us to love one another as much as you
loved us you love one another because
love is from God and often we do not
love those who we think are dirty hungry
lost or undesirable we have a hard time
loving those who were not like us who
disagree with us or who ask us to face
the truths about ourselves
El it is written that perfect love casts
out fear and yet we are afraid afraid
for our safety our wallets and how
others perceive us forgive us God and
show us how to love the way you command
us to love release us from our judgment
and our fear open our hearts so that
they might receive your perfect love for
us and offer it to the
world and Friends our ter of forgiveness
is this love is from God and we are
loved by God in creation God has
forgiven of God self and we are
forgiven okay and now we'll move into
communion so if those who are serving
will go ahead and get
ready um we're going to read our
communion liturgy
together I'm going to read the parts in
black and then we'll all read the parts
in red together
all right so the table of bread and wine
is now made to be
ready it is a table of company with
Jesus it is a table of sharing with the
poor of the
world it is a table of communion with
the
Earth so come to this table
come it is Christ who invited us to meet
Jesus here
[Music]
this last song um is just one of is
that every time I've heard the song
every time I sing it it is just such a
beautiful
reminder because in a lot of ways we're
just really not kind to ourselves and
especially when we do look in the mirror
and we like me and myself like I'm going
to be really honest and look in the
mirror and I just start being really
mean to myself trying to be honest like
honest and mean are not the same
thing and so this song you are welcome
can stand and sing with us or you can
sit but this is a beautiful song called
be
[Music]
kind you've got all that emotion that's
heing like otion and you're drowning in
a deep dark
well I can hear it in your voice that if
you only had a choice you would rather
be anyone
else I love you just the way that you
are I love the way he made Your Precious
Heart
be kind to
[Music]
yourself be kind to
yourself I know it's hard to hear it
when that anger in your spirit he
pointing like an arrow at your
Chas when the voice is in your mind or
anything but kind and you can't believe
your father knows
I love you just the way that you
are I love the way he's shaping your
heart be kind to
yourself be kind to
yourself oh how does it end in the war
that you're in is just you against you
against
you you got to learn to love learn to
love learn to love your enemies
[Music]
too you can't expect to be perfect it's
a fight you've got to Forfeit you belong
to me whatever you
do so lay down your weapon darling take
a deep breath and believe that I love
you be kind to
[Music]
yourself be kind to
yourself be
kind got to learn to love learn to love
learn to love enies
got learn to love learn to love learn to
love your
[Music]
enemies you got to learn to love learn
to love learn to love your
[Music]
enemies thank you so much for being with
us tonight um I hope that there was
something in the service that just
really connected with you at a heart
level at a head level and reminded you
that you were loved and that you were
not alone um what a gift to have Dr
Aaron brownbrook with us tonight
[Music]
yeah so so good
um licensed psychiatrist a chief medical
officer uh mix that with some theology
what a cool cool sermon message and gift
to our community so thank you so much
for that um and you can find Aaron on
social media you're welcome to chat with
him after the service is that okay not
okay we connect with Lance on social
media um but anyways what a great
service and uh remember we're going to
keep it going at hat Creek immediately
after the service if you are new or
relatively new here uh we're going to
put a QR code up on the screen we would
love for you to fill out our online
visitor card it just asks a couple
questions and allows us a chance to
connect with you and say thank you for
visiting with us tonight and just by the
way that QR code that we put up every
week goes to our link tree for the table
and has everything you would ever want
to know about meetups about um our
events that are going on our worship
playlist our podcast so it's a great
thing to just snap with your phone oh
there it is yay and uh a couple of those
slides that Aaron had up uh I'm going to
post those on our at the table Facebook
page so you can just search for at the
table under Facebook groups um and that
is on we have a link to that on our link
tree as well so you can scan the QR code
look for the Facebook group or you can
just go to Facebook and look it up we
always put our events we'll put uh aand
stuff up there and it's a great way to
just stay connected with the table
throughout the week all right I think
that's it um if you could all rise to
your feet I would love to send you out
into your week with a benediction which
is just a fancy word that means a
blessing for the road as you
go you were welcome to hold your hands
out uh in a spirit to receive these
words that I believe are true for each
and every one of you or you can just
open your heart to the
words you are a child of
God you are a child of
God this is true on your best
day and it's true on your worst
day so as you go out into your week
ahead with its yet to be determined
highs and lows and everything in
between go filled with the assurance
that you are loved you are worthy and
you are
accepted just as you
are and go filled with God's Holy Spirit
and the desire to extend these same
Gifts of Grace compassion and
unconditional love to everyone you come
in contact with be blessed have a good
week and we'll see you at hat Creek good
[Music]
night be kind of
yourself be kind is